contrairement aux chiffres régulièrement
avancé la france ne compte pas 56
réacteurs nucléaires en fonctionnement
en fait c'est un peu plus il y a aussi
les réacteurs militaire il s'agit pour
l'essentiel des onze moteur atomique
servant à la propulsion de nous sous
marins et du porte avions charles de
gaulle sauf que ces navires ils ne sont
pas éternels ils sont d'ailleurs voué à
être remplacé au cours des prochaines
décennies et les réacteurs nucléaires
iront rejoindre sur les côtes normandes
ceux de nos vieux submersible déjà en
cours de démantèlement la flotte
nucléaire française va être d'ici 2050
totalement renouvelée cherbourg sera
alors la première ville atomique du
monde accueillant dans son port
militaire 18 nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires ils seront stockés en attente
d'une diminution de la radioactivité sur
une durée minimale de 50 années avant
que puisse être entamé le processus de
démantèlement complet d'autant que les
moteurs atomique ne sont pas les seuls
déchets à prendre en compte il y a aussi
le combustible usé de la propulsion
navale où la matière de nos vieilles
d'ogives nucléaires par exemple des
rebuts radioactifs qui augmente et dont
le volume devrait presque doubler d'ici
2100 selon le rapport pour atteindre
près de 260 mille mètres cubes soit
environ 87 piscine olympique et encore
ne sont comptabilisés dans ce chiffre
que certains des résidus nucléaires
produits par notre défense nationale les
déchets enfouis volontairement dans le
sahara entre 1960 et 1967 durant les
essais nucléaires ou les laves
radioactives issues des accidents
nucléaires ne sont pas comptabilisés
d'autre part malgré l'absence depuis
plus de 20 ans d'une solution
industrielle au retraitement des 198
tonnes de combustibles usés hautement
radioactive de la marine nationale ceux
ci sont catégorisées comme des stocks de
matière et non comme déchets de même se
jeter près de 15000 tonnes en atlantique
nord-est dans les années 1960 ou encore
les chiffres qui évolue selon les
publications sur des sites de stockage
et d'entreposage zone nord et but de
pierrelatte fermé depuis de nombreuses
années pose question une
comptabilisation incomplète et
imprécises donc selon le rapport et qui
de plus manque de transparence et
surtout de contrôler les déchets
nucléaires militaires sont globalement
minimiser ou oubliées de la plupart des
études et rapports parlementaires
réalisées sur le sujet ayant trait aux
déchets nucléaires à la différence des
civils ils n'ont donc jamais fait
l'objet d'un suivi spécifique et d'un
contrôle régulier par les parlementaires
ce qui pose un problème démocratique
d'autant que les parlementaires ne
serait pas non plus totalement au fait
des coûts de démantèlement des
équipements nucléaires militaires
équipements dont ils votent tout de même
les financements pour résumer le secteur
de la défense produit depuis plus d'un
demi siècle une quantité de déchets
nucléaires dont le volume représente
aujourd'hui 9 % du stock global sans que
ces déchets soient correctement
comptabilisées ou même que les dépenses
qui les engendrent soit correctement
évalué